welcome to the video on basic
subtraction so what's subtraction
subtraction is essentially taking away
uh from something else so you learned
addition so let's see in addition and i
think i used avocados as the example
let's use something else i don't know
i'm using a
color as this this is like a but let's
do bananas use yellow
so we learned in in in addition and
basic addition that if we have
let's
say one
two bananas
and then we were to grow three more
bananas and i'll make the three new
bananas green because right when you
grow a banana before it has a chance to
ripen it's green so let's say i were to
grow three more bananas
three more bananas
and they look more like beans than
bananas but i think you get the idea
so we learned in basic edition that we
the total number of bananas we would now
have would be two
plus the three new ones that we just
grew
plus three
and you realize that that's
five and the other way to visualize that
was if we looked at a number line
let me do a draw a thicker number line
than that
let's say that this i'll do it in
magenta this color is magenta
so if you look at a number line
and this is zero
bananas
this is one
two
three
four
five
six and it just keeps going into larger
and larger numbers
so we said we started off with two
bananas
right and we grow we grew three bananas
so that took us three steps
larger on the number line or three steps
to the positive on the number line so
that would be
one
two three
so we got this far
so what's the total number of bananas we
have we have five we started at two and
we added three bananas okay so that was
a review of addition so what is
subtraction well subtraction is the
opposite
of addition when you when you when
you're adding two numbers at least we'll
deal with the positive numbers right now
i don't want to scare you too much
at your tender age
but
i don't actually i don't know how old
you are because this is a video
uh but i you know if we're dealing with
positive numbers when you add two
positive numbers you get a larger number
when you subtract two numbers
you'll get you're you're going to get at
least for now you're going to get a
smaller number so let's think about
subtraction
so let's start maybe i'll go back to
avocados because they're easier to draw
than bananas
so let's say i were to start with
and let's say
six avocados
how many is that one two three four five
six avocados
so i start with six avocados
start
six
avocados
i start with six avocados and let's say
i'm very hungry and despite the fact
that
avocados are calorie rich food i decide
to eat
four avocados
so i eat four avocados
so i eat
four avocados
my question to you is how many avocados
do i have left
let's see these are the these are my six
avocados one two three four five six
let's see this let's say that this one
looks particularly tasty and ripe and
ready to eat so so i i eat that one so
let's take that one away that doesn't
exist anymore so we're left with five i
told you i ate a total of four avocados
and let's say that this one also looks
awfully good so i eat this one i'm just
going right to left i could just say
this one looks good doesn't matter which
avocados i pick they're all equally
delicious
let's say i pick i don't know well i'm
going to start go from the right and go
to the left just so you have some
visualization of things
then i pick this avocado and i eat it
right
and i said four avocados how many how
many have i eaten so far i've eaten one
two
three avocados so i have to eat one more
in order to get my daily allowance of
avocados so i eat four avocados so the
question was
how many avocados do i have left well
look here i i had six i ate four of them
and right here i have two uneaten
avocados
so left
so avocados left
is going to be two
avocados
i should probably um
you're just probably learning to read
right now so i should probably use words
easier to spell than avocados but never
hurts to be exposed
so
we just did subtraction if i were to
write this without having to draw
avocados we would have said
six
minus you could view the eat as minus
taking away
so six minus four
avocados
is equal to
two avocados
if we go to the number line
let's think about that number line
hopefully you're reasonably familiar
with this point
let's look at that number line
so let's say that this is
zero
one
two
three
four i don't wanna bore you five
six and it just keeps going i could
extend this number line forever because
there's no largest number as you'll
learn later or as you could imagine
right if there was a largest number
i can always think of a bigger number
because i could add one to that number
but anyway let's go back to the problem
and not get too deep with
with
how large a number can get so how many
avocados did we start off with we
started off with six avocados
right
and we ate four or we could say we
subtracted four now remember when we
added if we added four avocados let's
say if we grew more four four more
avocados we would have gone to the right
four spaces on the number line but with
subtraction you go to the left on the
number line which makes sense you're
taking away right if i ate one avocado i
would have five left if i ate two
avocados i would have four left right so
the number of avocados is that i eat
is the number that i take i take a jump
to the left so it says i ate four
avocados so i ate one
two
three
four avocados
so i will go four spots to the left
when i eat my four avocados
and i will be left with
two avocados
let's do a couple of more examples and i
think you'll have a decent idea of of
how subtraction works oh actually and
let's think of it this way let's say
i want you to show how i want you to see
how addition and subtraction are related
to each other
let's say
that um
i were to tell you that i started with
six avocados
let me think about it the best way to
say let's say that i started with six
avocados so i said let me let me just
erase this i don't want to get too
crowded on the page
let's say i start with
six avocados
just like the last problem condos
and let's say someone comes into my room
and eats a bunch and i'm left with
i'm left with
two avocados i'll do it in a different
color
let's say i'm left with two avocados
my question is how many did the person
eat
how many did they eat
i don't know how many did they eat i
started with six and i'm left with two
how many did they eat
well there's a couple of ways to think
about it you could say
six avocados
minus
the amount of avocados eaten
is equal to two so the way you have to
think about it is
six minus what is equal to
two
right so let's think about it from the
number line or let's we could even draw
the avocados i'll draw them
i'll still draw them in green let's see
one two three four five six
so how many do i have to eat how many do
i have to take away to be left with two
let's say these are the two that i'm
left with so i would have to take away
these four
so essentially that person would have
had to eat have eaten four avocados
another way you could think about it is
what is the difference
between the number of avocados i started
with and the numbers of avocados that
i'm left with
so the way you think about difference is
what is how different is six and two and
that is how many must have been eaten
and so you could actually write it like
this
the difference between six
and two
is equal to the number of avocados that
are eaten and let me draw you a little
graph that might make a little more
sense of that let's say that that bar
represents six and you know six of
anything but in our example it's six
avocados
right
and let's say this bar here represents
how many were left
let's say that's two
so our question is how many were eaten
so this amount right here
had to be
what was eaten
and so you could view it as the
difference between six and two or
four
avocados
anyway i hope i didn't confuse you and i
hope that was a reasonable introduction
to subtraction let me know if you found
this daunting but i will see you in the
next video